[Music]  hi my name is michael and i'm a coda and  my name is beth and i'm a coda my name's  dave and i am a coda  [Music]  [Music]  it's just  so nice to see depictions of deaf people  beyond just being deaf to see my family  being depicted as a family when i share  that my parents are deaf it sounds like  terrible that everyone's like oh no  where i think being a code is so funny  sometimes yeah  [Music]  i just love a duck dad i don't know what  she's it's like and our dad's kind of  like that our dad is this really grand  character my dad really likes gangsta  rap because the bass  [Music]  is  [Music]  i thought that that was really poignant  because i've had that conversation i  didn't experience that but  [Music]  you know it's not my story i'm not ruby  but it kind of helped understand me  better  [Music]  you